>> Dana: THANK YOU, GRIFF.
>> Bill: THANK YOU.
TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT
JOINS US.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
SPECIFIC QUESTION.
HAS THE STATE OF TEXAS ASKED
WHETHER OR NOT THEY COULD TALK
TO THESE MIGRANTS TO GET MORE
INFORMATION FROM THEM AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THEY’VE BEEN
SUBJECTED TO TRAFFICKERS ALONG
THE WAY?
>> I HAVE.
I MADE A DIRECT PLEA TO THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION A COUPLE
OF DAYS AGO FOR TEXAS AND OUR
PROFESSIONALS IN THIS STATE
THAT DEAL WITH HUMAN
TRAFFICKING ALL THE TIME TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THESE MINORS WHO
HAVE COME ACROSS THE BORDER TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT HOW THEY WERE
TRAFFICKED HERE AND THEN WE
RECEIVED WORD YESTERDAY FROM
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION THAT
THEY WOULD ALLOW NO SUCH THING
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO CONTINUES
THE COVER-UP.
THE COVER-UP YOU’VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
THERE ARE TWO THINGS THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS TRIED
TO HIDE FROM THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
ONE IS THE MASSIVE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER.
AND THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION’S
LACK OF PREPARATION TO DEAL
WITH THIS MASSIVE NUMBER.
THE SECOND THING THEY WANT TO
HIDE IS THIS.
THAT IS WITH EVERY PERSON
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER, IT
EMPOWERS AND IT ENRICHES THE
DRUG CARTELS WHO ARE INVOLVED
IN EVERY SINGLE PERSON COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER, INCLUDING
THESE YOUNG CHILDREN.
THESE YOUNG CHILDREN COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER ARE VICTIMS
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
SOMEBODY HAS TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT.
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT I WANTED TO
DO NOT ONLY AS GOVERNOR BUT
WITH OUR PROFESSIONALS IN THE
STATE OF TEXAS WHO DEAL WITH
HUMAN TRAFFICKING ALL THE TIME.
WHO TRAFFICKED THESE KIDS INTO
THE STATE.
WHO IN THE STATE OF TEXAS IS
INVOLVED IN THIS SO WE CAN
ARREST THEM AND STOP THIS HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
THIS IS A CRISIS THAT IS BEING
MADE WORSE BY THE FACT THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
SUBJECTING EVEN MORE CHILDREN
TO COMING TO TEXAS OR COMING
ACROSS OUR BORDER WHO WILL BE
VICTIMIZED BY THESE CARTELS AND
THE CARTEL GANG MEMBERS WHO
COULD HARM THESE CHILDREN ALONG
THE WAY.
>> Bill: JUST TO BE CLEAR THEY
COULD BE SUBJECTED TO SEX CRIMES
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Bill: IF YOU AS THE GOVERNOR
OF THE STATE WANT TO LOOK INTO
IT YOU CAN’T FIND THAT OUT AND
HELP THEM.
>> EXACTLY.
SO EVERY DAY IN OUR OFFICE WE
HAVE A CHILD SEX TRAFFICKING
OFFICE IN THE GOVERNOR’S OFFICE
IN THE STATE OF TEXAS AND WE
ALSO HAVE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
OPERATIONS IN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL’S OFFICE TO CRACK DOWN
ON CRIMES LIKE THIS IN THE
STATE OF TEXAS ALL THE TIME.
THESE PROFESSIONALS ARE BEING
DENIED THE ABILITY TO CRACK
DOWN ON THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
THAT THESE CHILDREN ARE BEING
SUBJECTED TO ON THE TREK TO THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Dana: THEY’RE BEING TRACKED
ONCE THEY GET HERE.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC.
SECRETARY MAYORKAS AT A HEARING
BASICALLY SAID THEY HAVE
RELEASED MIGRANTS INTO THE
COUNTRY THAT HAVE COVID.
WATCH.
>> THERE WERE TIMES EARLIER
WHEN INDIVIDUALS WERE
APPREHENDED AND WE SOUGHT TO
EXPEL THEM AND WE WERE UNABLE
TO EXPEL THEM AND WE WERE
COMPELLED TO RELEASE THEM AND
WE DID NOT HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TEST THEM.
WE HAVE ADDRESSED THAT
SITUATION.
>> Dana: HAVE THEY ADDRESSED
THE SITUATION, SIR?
>> THEY HAVE BEGUN TO.
HOWEVER, DANA, THIS IS ANOTHER
COVER-UP AND TRY TO CAST THE
BLAME ELSEWHERE.
BY THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
IF YOU GO BACK ONE AND TWO
WEEKS AGO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION MADE IT FOUND
LIKE IT WAS MY FAULT AS THE
GOVERNOR OF TEXAS THAT THESE
CHILDREN AND OTHER PEOPLE
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER WERE
NOT BEING TESTED.
I SAID IT IS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION’S RESPONSIBILITY
TO DO THIS.
NOW MAYORKAS AND OTHER
OFFICIALS ARE ACKNOWLEDGING
PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THE BORDER
AND BEING RELEASED.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES
WITH THE PANDEMIC ARE ALL THE
DIFFERENT VARIANTS.
ONE IS COMING FROM BRAZIL.
THERE ARE OTHERS COMING FROM
ELSEWHERE.
WE NEED TO KNOW EXACTLY WHICH
COUNTRIES ALL OF THESE PEOPLE
ARE COMING FROM, WHAT VARIANTS
THEY MAY HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO,
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE TESTING
POSITIVE WHO ARE COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER.
WE’VE TRIED TO CONTAIN THE
SPREAD OF COVID-19 IN THE STATE
OF TEXAS.
NOW THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
IMPORTING MORE COVID INTO THE
U.S. BUT THEY COULD BE KEEPING
THEM OUT IF THEY WERE SECURING
THE BORDER.
>> Bill: TO BE CLEAR, GOVERNOR,
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DID
NOT LIKE THE POLICIES ON BEHALF
OF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION SO
THEY CHANGED THEM STARTING ON
INAUGURATION DAY AND THEY DID
IT IN THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE TO YOU?
>> IT IS A TOTAL DISASTER.
IT WOULD BE A DISASTER ANY TIME
BUT DURING THE TIME OF A
WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC AND BILL,
REMEMBER THAT ONE OF THE WORST
COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD FOR THE
SPREAD OF COVID, THE SO-CALLED
HOT ZONES IS MEXICO.
SO MANY OF THESE PEOPLE ARE
FOUGHT FROM MEXICO BUT TRAVEL
THROUGH MEXICO AND EXPOSED TO
COVID IN MEXICO.
SO WHAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING ON THE
ONE HAND TRYING TO SOLVE THE
PANDEMIC IN THE UNITED STATES
AND OTHER HAND IMPORT MORE
PANDEMIC INTO OUR COUNTRY.
THEY ARE NOT STEPPING UP AND
PROVIDING EITHER THE COVID
VACCINE TEST WHICH NOW THEY ARE
SAYING THEY’RE BEGINNING TO DO,
BUT ALSO THINK OF ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT THESE PEOPLE WHO
JUST CAME ACROSS THE BORDER
HAVE EXPOSED THEMSELVES TO AND
THOSE PEOPLE NEED ACCESS TO
VACCINES IMMEDIATELY AND THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
STEPPING UP AND PROVIDING THOSE
VACCINES.
>> Bill: THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY.
WE’RE IN TOUCH WITH YOU